hi everyone Sal Khan here and I'm with
Iman Howard who is our manager for all
of our stem content on Khan Academy we
wanted to welcome you to the Middle
School Earth and space Sciences course
Iman why should folks be excited about
this
so Middle School
in our universe and then like when you
dig in you're like what is happening in
our universe this is why we have seasons
and so we start like really big we go
all the way to outer space and we figure
out sort of Earth's position in our
solar system and the relationship to
gravity and our inner planets and our
outer planets and then we keep digging
in and we finally figure out how Earth's
position answer Seasons it's not because
we get closer to the Sun or how based on
Earth's position we look up at the moon
and you'll see a lunar eclipse or how
you don't look up and look at a solar
eclipse like seriously don't look up
because it'll hurt your corneas and then
we keep going and we talk about water
and how the same water that you're
drinking right now is the exact same
water that dinosaurs drink and then we
get into the rock cycle and we figure
out why mountains are here and how we're
moving right now literally the plates
below us are moving and how at one point
we could walk across all the way from
the U.S to Africa and how plate
tectonics really changed that and then
finally finally we talk about us
um we talk about us on this planet and
how there's so many amazing resources
here and how um well how we use them
really impacts the Earth and how that
could impact our climate and really
awesome things that you can do as a
learner to change all that and make this
Earth really awesome
what are you excited about Sal
well I'll just double down on everything
you did and I like how you said we're
going to dig into it because it's very
appropriate pun for her
but you know this this you know this
starts to answer the questions of you
know the from the cosmos to Earth over
billions of years as you mentioned the
Earth is alive in certain ways with the
plates are still moving it's active and
we should say at least and you know we
are part of the earth your point the
water in our bodies the air that we
breathe it's the same water and Earth
that has been we've been here in the air
for for billions and billions of years
so to be able to actually understand
that it it actually gives me gives me
goosebumps so I think folks will be very
excited about this course
absolutely